in the ocean they have no rival and on
cable they have their own week our
fascination with sharks has given
filmmakers endless opportunities to prey
on audiences fears turning this off
misunderstood prehistoric species into a
bloodthirsty killing machine even if
you're not in the water sharks in the
desert sharks and space sharks in the
tornado
or sharks who come back from the dead to
haunt you in your backyard shark movies
are now firmly embedded as their own
sub-genre let's take a look at some of
our most beloved movie starring
Hollywood's favorite maneater shark
Night 3d if you were a teenager in a
movie why would you ever go to a lake
nothing good ever happens there that
goes double if you're trapped on an
island with no cell service and your
ex-boyfriend and his buddy fill the
water with sharks so they can film the
carnage despite some neat twists slick
production values for the genre and Sara
Paxton katharine McPhee and bikinis
shark Night 3d was ultimately sunk by a
pg-13 rating and near comical death
scenes but hey at least the dog survives
open water the premise pure nightmare
fuel a couple on a scuba diving vacation
are accidentally left behind with a lot
of sharks when their boat crew forgets
about them while the film is more of an
exercise in psychological horror and
focuses on the broken relationship
between the two main characters the
constant and palpable fear that a shark
may strike at any time
makes open water one of the most
terrifying shark movies in recent memory
the only happy ending it made 10 times
more than its $500,000 budget deep blue
sea if you can ignore a premise that
involves scientists thinking that mako
sharks are like the best cure for
Alzheimer's disease because sharks
brains don't age apparently you can
appreciate this outrageously fun b-movie
it's got genetically altered super-smart
sharks going ham that's hard as a mako
friend in an underwater research
facility and if that weren't enough for
our team of scientists to worry about
the screenwriters do in an impending
hurricane just because boasting
incredible CGI for its time and samuel
l.jackson chewing up all the scenery
with sharks left behind deep blue sea
has earned cult classic status plus you
can't beat that LL Cool J rap theme
pure magic bait you have to at least
give the Australian production bait a
few points for originality the last
thing you'd expect after a freak tsunami
is shark swimming down the frozen food
section at your local grocery store
which by some miracle still has
electricity yet here they are and
they're the most believable thing in the
movie you can tell everyone involved
really tried to make something serious
here
but how serious can it be when the hero
takes out a great white with the Taser
this would probably be considered a
classic by now if the filmmakers had
been a bit more self-aware and called it
sharks in a grocery store chalk that up
to a missed opportunity if a group of
mildly annoying survivors trapped in a
supermarket with sharks is your thing
make sure to add this to your queue the
reef another classic from Australia
2010's the reef prove that you don't
need a big budget or a convoluted plot
to give you audience legit scares the
tale of five friends who set out for
Indonesia only the capsized on a reef as
an exercise in hopelessness do they stay
with a boat and risk the very real
possibility of dying of thirst and
exposure or attempt swimming to shore in
shark-infested waters no unnecessary CGI
no cliched tropes just people in the
water slowly being eaten alive one by
one
delicious Soul Surfer real-life events
can be difficult to dramatize but the
true story of surfer Bethany Hamilton
getting her left arm ripped off by a
tiger shark and her subsequent struggle
to surf again was a story made for
celluloid based on Hamilton's 2004
autobiography Soul Surfer a true story
of faith family and fighting to get back
on the board it didn't blow critics away
but found a home among audiences who
liked their shark attacks with an
inspirational message of hope of course
for the audience's who have no need for
dumb things like hope or inspiration
bears sharknado
sci-fi sharknado knows full well that
it's a movie about well a shark tornado
and it embraces that insane premise with
every friend in between the actors
winking at the camera sharknado gives
you some of the most outrageous and
over-the-top sharks to ever hit the big
screen running down the B movie
checklist and marking off many items
more than once this movie can even be
considered a work of art considering the
glorious lengths
to not take itself seriously the
dialogue is almost as bad as the color
correction the character development is
more unbelievable than the plot and the
CGI is almost as painful as the
one-liners but you know what it works it
delivers in every way possible if you
don't like sharknado you don't like fun
blue water white death the only
documentary on our list blue water white
death follows filmmaker and underwater
photo journalist peter gimbals arduous
nine-month trek across the globe to
capture the great white shark on film
for the very first time and where did he
find one right where he probably should
have started South Australia with
spellbinding footage gimbal shows us the
legendary great white and it's full and
terrifying glory fun facts crew members
Ron and Valerie Taylor provided Steven
Spielberg with the great white footage
for Jaws speaking of which jaws the
opening sequence of Steven Spielberg's
jaws boasts the most terrifying shark
attack ever filmed and you never even
see the shark the sense of building
dread as you watch police chief Brody
try and repeatedly failed to convince
officials in his coastal town to close
the beach during peak tourist season is
enough to make you never want to set
foot in an ocean again John Williams
iconic score will make you pause before
entering a pool we won't even mention
the classic lines because you know them
all okay maybe just one
I need a bigger boat
so good of course a movie this good just
has to have a sequel right jaws to just
when you thought it was safe to go back
in the room now that's a tagline for
sequel a sequel we might add that Roy
Scheider only agreed to star in to get
out from under his contract at Universal
it's debatable whether even Spielberg
could have saved the script for jaws -
and you think a madhi's mayor would be
more inclined to listen to police chief
Brody when he cries shark this time
around but despite not coming close to
the original jaws - does offer up some
scary moments as well as perhaps the
greatest shark electrocution death scene
in movie history
what why
well not that there are too many shark
electrocution death scenes choose from
but you get the idea seriously though no
matter how many bad sequels that spawned
the original Jaws is without a doubt the
greatest shark movie of all time past
present and future maybe it's time we
stop making them after we get sharknado
4 of course thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to see
more videos like the one you just saw
leave us a comment to let us know which
shark movie was your favorite